welcome to this video playing floating
self funny name I never played him let's
see a French defence his play he saw
from from Canada yeah I played them he
played the advanced variation yeah
Bishop d3 decision somewhat
old-fashioned approach it's not terribly
dangerous but also not particularly bad
here Black is comfortable because he
gets the bishops very without any any
problem okay maybe a six I can take it
start with this is no we used to spend
the temple yeah here gt5 is a very
tempting move and I do that come on it's
very tempting because black gets this
active position on the Kings side maybe
get in h5 h4 and let's play quickly for
change and getting rid of this defender
of the d4 pawn so there is Queen Queen
v6s em as an interesting try what I need
to always be aware of our the piece sex
like night XD 585 e6 this is potentially
dangerous okay so should I play um a
safe move maybe this one I can still
play Queen B 6 but I want to move to to
close the house so that this 95 business
is not so easily happening
and Queen B 6 is them the next move on
the agenda yeah again this is some an
issue but I can play that
yeah Roxy form is quite nice relief
occupying this this square and maybe I'm
even threatening to take on default I'm
not one hundred percent sure it can be
can be somewhat tricky I guess ok Bishop
g5 move look see to push up g 5 + + h 5
may be threatening each form I'm Mestel
it still looks a bit shaky this is set
up with the night on a 501c4 but I don't
see em a technical drawback really don't
yeah tough tough to play in forum for
white ok this is I was something that
obviously neglected does the square H
form yeah it was basically trapping
trapping the bishop so what see what is
this IDM night a form maybe but still
age form okay I'll show me I could have
taken on d4 with the book hello why
didn't I take on d4 with the rook and he
just gives up and now I see it right
after I played a playdate form I mean
maybe it is yeah no f5 were singing him
and believer sometimes
okay it's still it's still not totally
clear check of course I never do the
other thing is just just to win outright
ruta 40 resigns this is it however it
seems is also possible look queen g5
there is Luke cakes and I still have the
bishop trapped if you take skin takes
leadership is strapped okay kim takes
you actually can take and play d5 so
maybe this one is better I'll take the
end I came on this should be secured
some protected protected porn on the
third-ranked really should should help
check yeah there's some caution here
always with stale matrix but he still
has this be three bond useful so book
takes like or whatever signs would have
been much much easier yeah endo just
here rookie form here I mean and it's
simply simply over through going here
this is this is gone black wins the
house minus seven and h4 it's just the
sheer luck that this thing is not not
killing me oh it is actually killing me
if he plays it right okay here Quincy
sixes and with which I didn't consider
of course based on the fact that there
is syrup takes deform amazing okay this
happened check and this is a mistake you
should have taken on c4 first check
right here I'm Jan I'm winning again
well this isn't isn't totally clear yeah
yeah that's not clear I mean this is
what two pawns for the exchange not not
very good really
unclear when we compute the likes black
but that's not that's not easy to play
really if i get if i get the the rooks
into play I'm fine but hmm everything
else but but easy okay thanks for
watching